so there's a great oscar wilde quote
which is that everything in life is
about sex except for sex which is about
power when you think about seduction you
probably think about in a rather narrow
sense in terms of erotic seduction or
sexual seduction but what if I were to
suggest to you seduction is a much
deeper wider more mysterious thing and
actually at the heart of it
is the secret to success in life my name
is dr. Roger sword I'm a consultant
psychiatrist I wrote a book on the
psychology of seduction as being the key
secret at the heart of successful
relationships
so I'm tempest rose I'm an international
burlesque performer creative director
and teacher and producer if you think
about your average day and the way you
make your way through your average day
and the people you meet your work
colleagues your friends and people who
might serve you in restaurants and so on
if you learn the art of seduction and
you seduce these people into liking you
and therefore delivering what you want
you'll find it much easier to navigate
your way through life well let's perform
is a good at seduction because we're
trained to understand that we make
choices in how we present our art to the
audience on stage we learn to use our
seduction techniques consciously and so
I know that if I cast my eyes the way
the audience will focus on a certain
part of my costuming or if I move in a
certain way it draws attention to a part
of my body and that will be part of the
story that I want to tell within my act
so we learn to be very aware of even
just a glance of the eye or a stroke of
the hand on the body we use all of these
tools to direct the audience's gaze
because we want to tell them a story so
all of these micro movements are really
really important in getting to grips
with how you direct the audience to
watch your act and absorb what you're
trying to tell them when we perform
burlesque a - oh we're clowning ideas of
what attraction is and of what sexuality
is and what seduction is we're playing
with what might be called the
traditional feminine arts and we're
using those as a springboard really to
play with the audience about ideas of
power and ideas of enticement seduce men
and glamor as well
find out what that person's unmet need
is and then fill it in a way it's never
been filled before in my clinic people
come in and they're often unhappy why
are they unhappy they're unhappy because
they're frustrated with the world the
world is not giving them what they want
is not giving them a pay rise not giving
them a date with the people they want to
have a date with it's not giving them
popularity or love or affection and so
people are upset and they have a
demanding approach to the world why is
the world not giving me what I want so
in order to get what you want from the
world you need to understand this basic
transaction you're gonna have to give
something to the world to get that thing
that you want the problem is we're
always thinking about our own unmet
needs and distracts us from focusing on
the person in front of us what are they
after in life what drives them what
moves them forward and in particular
what their key frustrations are a lot of
small talk in terms of passing the time
of day doesn't seem to be very directed
but seductive people are actually using
small talk in a particular way what
they're doing is they're figuring out
the direction your life is traveling in
now trying to figure out what it is that
drives you forward what it is that you
want what it is that you need what it is
that frustrates you they're getting
inside your head and that's the best way
to find out what the unmet need is and
then to fill it in a way that it's never
been filled before
[Music]
one of the things that I really want
your audience to go away feeling is that
there is no one rule about how to be
attractive how to be sexy how to be
seductive because each of us have our
own individual power and the importance
of burlesque is to be an antidote to the
one-dimensional idea that there is only
one way to do these things so each
performer really roots into their
individuality and then we magnify it to
make this huge explosion of individual
gravitas and attraction and seduction
most people have very low self esteem
about the idea that they could learn to
be seductive they believe you're either
born with it
you're either drop-dead gorgeous or
you're not think seduction is a
learnable skill what I mean by that is
anyone can learn to be seductive and
certainly to be more seductive so if you
learn the skills of seduction you can be
as seductive as any of the most gorgeous
people you've met in your life thanks
for watching don't forget to subscribe
and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon